for probably another month or so for the
suspension oh no
paul george make us proud bounces off
the backboard
[Applause]
they're saying defense to offense
clipper fans
that's what you're going to see all year
long kawhi lin
it's a trade they would do 10 times out
of 10. here is
[Music]
six minutes of the game he only has five
shots
in the last 15 that he's played
flying around staples center like he's
got a jet pack on
here in isolation situation nice lob
right there
flopping that goal flippers by one
westbrook taken away by harrell inside
jamichael greene
the nice dip balls can you look at it do
you pass that along to other blue
doubles
oh my goodness
what a pass by jerome robinson you can
see the air up there
and matress finished with authority
right at that rim
that was the assist of the game brought
to you by carmax
i thought uh cap mobley said it best we
haven't discussed
this before montrez
taking any and all challenges to cask
count it and a foul
[Music]
george bullies his way to the rim wrap
around pass to montrez counted on a foul
back andres watch this forces his way
through brings the third defender over
and then finishing while the defender is
hanging on him tres the strong finish
was the morongo good times moment
montrez had 12.
lou with the steal
lob to tres up high and powers of end
with two
five point game five ten to play
really early once he's intercepted like
right here
i thought he was gonna try to pass it to
montrez good decision
lou
[Music]
[Applause]
understanding that he only had a second
and a half to go he had to get it up on
the rim lou williams and there was
trez on the weak side forcing his way
inside to keep it alive 26 points
for montrez harrell off the bench
scratch that make it 24
in the biggest bucket of the game
once again it will count
and the way that he would iso take space
face the floor kind of post you up get
you in spots where you couldn't guard he
had a heck of a pump fake
beautiful pass right there in dunk by
[Music]
coming up on a minute remaining in the
third
couch and the foul sweeping
to the rim except that when you set the
screen you play unselfish
you either have the corners open or you
have the strong
finish inside
[Applause]
harold's so skilled but more importantly
checking into the game
for the first time on the prowl around
bobner to the rim swiveling to freedom
and leaves at home
did i mention the wizards have the worst
defense in the league oh you didn't have
to
translate through intentions unleashes a
fury at the rim
okay that's what you want
right to left crossover
it doesn't matter if he leaves it anyway
to say
he was banged up and hurt when he played
against him and i say the same thing
this dude was just unbelievable in the
way that he passed the basketball and
shot the three ball crews trail by two
after having led by five moments ago
mantras spots an entry to the house oh
my
hello nasty to play here
does a good job of just a little
misdirection
just magruder deals back to patterson
late in the clock again
the first could go two for one here
mantra is down the lane
down the hatch counted on a foul
he's just such a hard player to guard i
mean that was a good foul
that was the month we talked about it in
our open that why london really seemed
to find his rhythm with this team
deflection interception montrez on a
mission in transition gets it to
magruder to the rim
and lays it in
[Music]
[Applause]
match their largest lead at five fresh
shakes free jams at home
counting on a foul swimming with
confidence here in downtown los angeles
[Music]
kawhi back door lookout takes it to the
house and powers it in
nice drawing up play right there coach
malone
[Applause]
lou in trouble they get it to trez
oh a seductive ball fake counted and
give him one more on the house
wow answering the ball in the double
team by lou and a nice zip
knowing that that rotation guy plumly
was just double teaming
in the pick and roll he's going to be a
step late nice job right there by pat
david i'd love to say that but i just
i think i'd be a little a bit of a
fibber right there
i think we all know that montrese turns
it over here's garland the other way
rebuked out of boundary
stay with the cavaliers montrez
frustrated with himself
coach here in south florida mike brown
not to be confused with the longtime
cavaliers and lakers head coach that was
about to say not to mike
brown unless he has an mma career that
you you were unaware of
williams gets it rejected
[Applause]
eric jones with the block and then
waiters turns it over
harrell spinning away from olynyk drives
and
finishes always the toughest for the
officiating crew
blue transition to heartless in traffic
no lays it up and in counted on a foul
but he healed a couple of games to go 42
off the bench
great ball movement here's shamit for
three got it
that's almost exactly as they practiced
today
at the shoot around picking up the
sarcasm here is leonard hands to
montrez back to kauai pinned beneath the
net muscles up a shot anyway
once again cut the lead they keep coming
they keep coming man they're passing the
ball
some unusual other calls made
there's harold oh he puts it down
resume it will be clipper ball just a
powerful move there by
montrez harold and he was saying hit me
on my header you know that 12 30 game
that means that it will be an early
shoot around
and shoot around start early as crest
gets down the floor nice one-on-one
defense
by a guy that's playing well landry had
the wherewithal to throw it up
nice play by montreal
because i wanted to kiss my 200 people
no i wasn't running people over
the purpose of that was to get the team
in the penalty
and you got them independently that
helped our team out nothing back
stepping back he said okay that's fine
anderson rebuked at the cuff by montrez
and lou williams out rivals anderson
lobs
takes it to the household and he shakes
the southland
flushing it in with two absolutely
and in this day and age his size at the
center spot's not a problem harold
oh he hits a three he was
0 for 17 from downtown
and the streak is over i think the
streak is going to
remain intact you are a party pooper
i i am but i was right so
i'm sorry just the facts here for the
los
angeles clippers he continues to sit
with a calf injury there's a block by
harrell
[Applause]
clippers have tightened up defensively
harold goes to the hole gets a friendly
roll
[Applause]
[Music]
doncic keeps kawhi behind him runs into
his own teammate
and here comes reggie jackson showing
off the handle the drive
the dish shamit the catch the swish
jackson into tres he'll fling the three
oh
[Applause]
three ball threes please
and then we know 19 points on the
regular season
and hasn't found his stride offensively
as well for the clippers
and they go to porter inside what a
rejection
by harold my goodness the collision you
can hear it from way up here
here's the blocked shot by montrez
harold
on porter jr i mean this is meeting you
at the summit my friend
as jokic continues to gather himself
final seconds
on the move williams harold count it
pretty shot with a great pass